this is a simple example of the
geolocation API you call get current
position and pass it a callback and the
callback is called when it gets your
location and gives you your latitude and
longitude there's also a very similar
watch position call which does the same
thing except continually calls you every
time the position is updated let's walk
through how we use this API in our
conference app first we added a button
to the map page that triggers the
geolocation procedure when this button
is pressed the trigger geolocation
method in our code is called this code
is the heavy lifting of the trigger
geolocation method this uses the html5
geolocation API method get current
position and passes it a success
callback and an error call back it also
enables high accuracy and sets a timeout
in case of failure we print a generic
sorry we couldn't find your location on
the other hand if we succeed we call a
method called elaborate distance
elaborate distance uses the root method
from the Google Maps direction service
to obtain an object containing
information about the route between the
users position and the venue it then
displays some of this information and
allows you to open up google maps with
the route already set obviously this is
frequently the way that you'll use
geolocation data that is passing it off
to another control most of us don't
write code that uses this latitude and
longitude directly